they've got him now oh they've got him
now
the democrats have uncovered president
trump's wait for it
secret chinese bank account they found
that secret
chinese bank account in his tax records
all the blue checkmarks are talking
about it
oh alyssa milano did you read her
twitter yesterday
china trump has a secret bank account in
china for a number of years
paid more in taxes in china than he did
federal income tax to the united states
even barack obama is talking about the
secret bank account
on the campaign trail we know that he
continues to do business with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i had a secret chinese
bank account
when i was running for re-election well
barack obama obviously wouldn't have a
secret chinese bank account because he
never did any business anywhere in his
life so he
he entered office and then he made a lot
of money in
office by selling his influence and
selling his books and things like that
but how did they find that secret
chinese bank account from his tax
records i guess they
they went in and then if it was on the
tax records
i guess it probably couldn't be secret
sounds like it's all a bunch of nothing
to distract away
from hunter and joe biden's business
dealings in china
if that's the best october surprise
they've got to deflect
against the hard drive full of crimes
that the republicans have uncovered with
regard to the bidens
the next couple weeks are going to get
very very interesting i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from
aegis reflector who says blm biden's
laptop matters
that's the only blm i want to hear about
that is absolutely true
biden's laptop does matter you're seeing
a situation right now
where the real scandal of the hunter
biden laptop and the emails and the text
messages
showing lots of evidence of crimes being
committed
by the biden family and apparently some
evidence of
underage girls is being pushed out of
the news
for completely bs narratives that the
trump secret
bank account is just the tip of the
iceberg
because the a secret bank account on
your tax records is by definition not
secret
because you're reporting it on your tax
records but
the bs narratives are going into
overdrive okay
this is not painting a very good picture
of november
for the democrats but you know what does
paint nice pictures paint yourlife.com
that's what
if you want to give a truly meaningful
gift you have got to try
paintyourlife.com you get a professional
hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price you can choose from a
team of world-class artists you work
with them
until every detail is perfect i just had
one done of my mother
uh you can actually see it on my
instagram if you go to my instagram you
can see it's like i think one of the
first
uh pictures up there it was unbelievable
and i was working with the team
you know back and forth and back and
forth on okay here's the photo but i
don't want it to look exactly like the
photo i want the background to be a
little bit different you go back and
forth the whole time
and you get a custom-made hand-painted
portrait i had mine done in oil
you can order it in less than five
minutes and by the way it gets done
pretty quickly after that makes the
perfect holiday gift for someone you
love and in my case that someone is me
so i love me and
i had it done it's wonderful and it can
really add a lot of beauty to your house
at paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love your painting your final
painting
your money is refunded guaranteed and
right now is a limited time offer you
get 20
off your painting 20 off and free
shipping
to get this special offer text michael
to 64 000 that is m-i-c-h-a-e-l to 64
000.
michael to 64 000. text it paint your
life celebrate the moments that matter
most
the reason we're seeing the dem
narrative go into overdrive is because
the democrats do not have an october
surprise and the republicans do
so that they have to just contrive the
october surprises so they'll say
trump trump called the troops losers or
something you say well do you have any
evidence of that they'll say no
okay or they'll say trump has a secret
bank account
and say well do you have any evidence of
that say yes tax records so then it's
not secret
uh rudy giuliani as well rudy giuliani
this is my favorite one
this is my favorite one they're cooking
this up because
republicans have the october surprise
republicans have the receipts
and specifically rudy giuliani actually
has the receipts he's been
breaking day by day by day this hunter
biden
slash joe biden scandal so they're going
after rudy here's the big story you
probably saw this on twitter
rudy giuliani was filmed with his hands
down his pants in a hotel room
with a 15 year old girl that's the story
okay that's the headline that you're
seeing except that didn't happen
rudy giuliani was doing an interview for
the new borat movie
and obviously the way borat now works is
borat just tries to
to get a bunch of republican figures to
humiliate themselves
so they go they shoot in this hotel room
and
there wasn't a 15 year old girl there
was a 24 year old girl there
and they're in the room and then there's
this compromising photo of rudy giuliani
with his hand being tucked into his belt
underneath his belt rather so what's
happening here is rudy
in the midst of some obscene act you
know like the act that jeffrey tuban
just committed that the whole left wing
is trying to say we should forgive
and forget about and bring him back onto
tv
opinion articles about this going around
all yesterday no it's not what's
happening at all
even according to the editorial director
of mother jones maybe the most
far left-wing outlet out there no love
lost between mother jones and rudy
giuliani
this guy tweets out i have now seen the
scene with rudy giuliani and though it
is creepy
for other reasons it is being described
on twitter in a false way
he does not have his hand down his pants
in a sexual way he is tucking his shirt
back in after she untucks it removing
his mic
i knew this the minute i saw the story i
said this something about this story
doesn't smell right to me
there's no video no one can actually see
the scene they're trying to push this
borat movie both
to make money on the movie and they're
releasing it around this time
so that it can have an effect on the
election i said okay we're not getting
the video
the movie was screened months ago and
nobody brought this up then
and if if you've ever done an interview
you know
that when you take your microphone off
no matter where the mic pack is it could
be in your pocket it could be
down your pants it could be in your on
the back of your belt but no matter
where you put it if the mic is being run
up
your shirt your shirt will come undone
you've got to tuck your shirt back in
that happens to everybody well why was
he in the hotel room well i don't know i
assume that the borax crew
had him filming in the hotel room why
was borat in the hotel room because he
busted in after and then had the punch
line
apparently at the scene which is no no
she's 15 she's too old for you
which is kind of funny writing but the
whole setup is is pretty ugly because
it's not legitimate we now have evidence
that hunter biden had
underage pornography on his laptop we
know that jeffrey toobin
just uh had a lot of fun with himself on
a work call
both of those being pushed out of the
news right both of these left-wing
scandals one in the media one
in the political realm because rudy
giuliani tucked in his microphone it's
just a little too
convenient and it's just bs
another example of this another i'll
actually give you the left wing and the
right-wing example of this
so the narrative that we have seen in
the recent weeks
so in michigan now we've seen it
elsewhere around the country is that
fake
is that rather that right-wing
extremists are sending threatening
emails
to intimidate democrat voters
this particular narrative started a few
weeks ago with gretchen whitmer where
they said
right-wing extremists are plotting to
kidnap the the democratic governor of
michigan
say i bet that's not true and then you
find out who these people are and
they've got all big sorts of crazy
earrings and they've got
anarchist signs on the back of the wall
and they hate donald trump and they're
obviously
not i don't know that they're
necessarily a left-wing extremist
they're certainly not right-wing
extremists and probably just anarchists
and anarchy goes to the left
so this new one is that they're sending
emails around to intimidate democratic
voters except the director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe just
confirmed on wednesday
that iran the world's leading state
sponsor of terror
is the one behind the emails iran is
sending the emails pretending to be
right-wing extremists to try to damage
president donald trump
and they just got caught doing it why
are they doing this because trump is
tough on iran and
joe biden sends them pallets of cash
that's why
so that narrative completely debunked
but there are intimidating messages
that are being sent to voters the
reality is though
those messages are coming from the
democrats the reality of it is
democrats are threatening physical
violence against trump supporters we've
got the receipts
you know you know sometimes when i go
into an auto parts store
i uh i don't get my receipt because i
don't know what part to get because i
walk out of there
i would recommend going to rockauto.com
instead
because you go to rock auto they've got
all the parts available for your car or
truck
they're a family owned business they
have always reliable
low prices and it's so simple even i can
navigate it okay you go to rockauto.com
you shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers and best
of all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low
and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
why on earth would you spend up to twice
as much for the same parts or why would
you
go into the brick and mortar store when
they're not even going to have the part
and then they're going to go to
rockauto.com they're going to order it
and then they're going to charge you
double you can see all those parts
for your car truck at a glance a
wonderful selection head on over to
rockauto.com and then
this is most important of all in the how
did you hear about us box
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s so that they
know that we sent you these guys
have been in the business online
basically for as long as there has been
an online
and they always have great service and
great parts available
rockauto.com write knowles in there how
did you hear about us box
and i promise you you will not regret it
so the reality here is democrats are
sending these threatening messages
this is happening in new hampshire this
is happening according to the
milford police department trump
supporters are receiving
this message in the mail dear neighbor
you've been identified by our group as
being a trump supporter your address has
been added to our database as a target
when we attack should trump not concede
the election
we recommend that you check your home
insurance policy and make sure that it
is current
and that it has adequate coverage for
fire damage you have been given fair
warning as always
it was you that started this civil war
be prepared to face the severe
consequences of your pre-emptive actions
against democracy
this is probably just a bunch of little
punks you know who aren't gonna
do anything but the people receiving
these messages can't rely on that
because don't forget democrats have been
burning the country down for the last
seven months
so you might say michael
maybe this is a foreign power sending
these physical messages to people in the
middle of new hampshire
you know just like they're doing over in
iran
i think that's probably unlikely you
know i think if it were a foreign power
would probably be cyber
uh but let's say it's possible i mean
the milford police department is
treating this as though
it's legitimate left-wingers who are
sending these messages but
let's say it's an open question the
reason it's more likely that the
democrats are actually doing that is
because the democrats
have actually been threatening trump
supporters with physical violence
and committing physical violence against
trump supporters since
april i don't know so when did they
start burning the country down they're
still burning the country down
since even before then as always the
democrats projecting
they're accusing the republicans of
doing the very things
that the democrats themselves are doing
got another narrative bs narrative
cooked up over the past month or so
that narrative is that trump is not a
patriot trump hates the troops he's a
vicious anti-american guy
remember they cooked up that fake story
in the atlantic and said trump called
soldiers losers
he called them suckers and this was
confirmed with
all anonymous sources and then then they
called some more anonymous sources and
the anonymous sources confirm the
anonymous sources
meanwhile you had 26 officials go on the
record even officials who don't like
trump and say yeah
i was in the room that never happened so
how do they cook that one up
they do it because they themselves very
often don't like america
ilhan omar you know ilhan omar she's
she's the one who giggles at the at the
idea of al qaeda
and and describe 911 as some people did
something
ilan omar went on msnbc to insist that
she loves
our country more than president trump
does i mean it's it's
really also just astonishing to see
uh the way in which he characterizes
what love for our country is
i would certainly reckon you know not
only somalis but myself
the governor of michigan our speaker all
love
this country um way more than the
the president who is not only destroying
the presidency but
everything this country stands for so
obviously that's not true right nobody
in their right mind believes that ilhan
omar loves america more than donald
trump donald trump doesn't giggle at al
qaeda
donald trump doesn't give aid and
comfort to our enemies
around the world donald trump doesn't
describe 911 as some people did
something
but just recently just two days ago i
think
aoc and ilhan omar participated in an
event
with someone named hassan [ __ ] i
i did a panel with this guy once on some
tv news show
and uh he was very polite to me
i don't know maybe he didn't want me to
bring up some of the things he said in
the past
but this is a very radical guy so
sometimes he plays nice
sometimes he doesn't play so nice one
time he didn't play so nice
was when he was describing dan crenshaw
you know friend of the show you've seen
him before
dan crenshaw who's a war hero lost his
eye in battle defending our country
against our enemies
hassan [ __ ] i don't think he exhibited
a whole lot of patriotism
in his comments about dan crenshaw this
guy
has the understanding of foreign policy
of like a 12 year old
what the what is wrong with this dude
didn't he go to war and like literally
lose his eye because some
mujahideen a brave soldier [ __ ] his
eye hole
with their isn't that how he lost his
side
because he got us i hope america
deserved 9 11 dude
i'm saying it all right well that's
that's one opinion not my opinion not
the opinion of people who love america
that is the opinion of people who hate
america
who hate their country who hate the
troops
who do all the things that the left is
accusing
the right of doing the left is accusing
trump of doing and aoc and ilhan omar
two of the most prominent congressmen
now in the democratic caucus
just did a very happy-go-lucky event
with him it was a twitch stream with
hassan [ __ ] and uh and that yet they
continue to insist that they love their
country more than trump does anybody
believe that no
what they're really saying is i hate my
country
but i love what our country could be if
i were permitted to transform it i mean
this is the same argument that barack
obama made
barack obama put it in nicer terms he
didn't talk like that guy hassan [ __ ]
but he said essentially the same thing
that the progressive left is saying
when they associate with people who hate
america
namely i i promise to fundamentally
transform america
obama said he wanted to fundamentally
transform america and it is simply a
fact
that you don't try to fundamentally
transform things that you love
you you try to fundamentally transform
things that you don't love to make them
lovable to you and that's what the left
wants and those are the stakes of this
election because the left is promising
yet again
to fundamentally transform this country
last time in 2016 mike anton over at the
claremont institute
uh wrote something called the flight 93
essay
big essay right this essay gave kind of
the intellectual framework for trumpism
and he said that 2016 election is like
the flight 93
incident where you had terrorists take
over
the plane and you had heroes get up and
storm the cockpit
and they knew that if they stormed the
cockpit there was still a very good
chance the plane was going to crash
but they knew that if they didn't storm
the cockpit the plane was certainly
going to crash
so it was the only option available to
them
almost desperate not quite desperate in
the sense that there was still a little
hope that it could go
go well but they just knew the the only
way to exhibit any courage here
is to just go out and take the chance
i've got and mike anton said that
there's a political
analogy here which is that trump is our
guy that we know
hillary is going to i don't know mixing
metaphors but
drive the country off a cliff as barack
obama used to say and
we know that that's going to happen and
we don't know about donald trump so
you've got to go for donald trump
now people are going to say well what is
this another flight 93 is this another
flight 93
mike anton says in his new book yeah
they're all going to be flight 93
elections until we can write
this this radicalism that is is going on
in the country
every single one of these it's actually
going to become more urgent than the
last election
because the demands are going to get
more radical
now one thing i've noticed about demands
is that women demand that men have nice
hair i've noticed this i don't know if
it just happened to me maybe you've
noticed it too
did you know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered
right to your home they make it easy
they deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved
hair loss products out there you may
have tried them before but you've
probably never tried them for this price
you know i'm no hulking adonis of a man
okay i'm not
not telling any tales at a school okay i
say this with all
no false modesty one thing i've always
had going in the lady department is my
hair and you should try to keep your
hair
as well if you're ready to take action
to prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
slash knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash knowles keeps
and keep your hair head on over there
right now
so my canton's point is it's always
going to get more and more and more
urgent you see it in that letter that
these republicans are getting in north
carolina
not north carolina and new hampshire
which is that we're going to have a
civil war if trump wins how dare
you can't let trump win and so they're
getting increasingly
desperate however but before we move on
to to some of the other way the election
shaking out because there is good news
i do have to get to the most ridiculous
narrative of all
forget about the giuliani nonsense
forget about donald trump's secret
bank account that we all knew about it
was honest taxes forget about all of
that the most ridiculous narrative that
the left is pushing right now
is that president trump is
envious of hillary clinton here is
chelsea clinton pushing this idea
he's obsessed with her i mean he talks
about it
[Applause]
he talks about her in interviews he
talks about her in rallies he
tweets about her and i think it's really
clear
that he has never gotten over the fact
that she won by the popular vote by more
than three
million votes and i think that
he's also really threatened by strong
powerful women
you know i don't think it's an accident
that we saw kind of how he reacted to
senator harris's extraordinary debate
performance
um which similarly he felt quite
threatened by so
i'm not surprised although i certainly
wish she spent more time
thinking about what to do about her
covid crisis than thinking about my mom
kamala harris looked like she was going
to cry during that debate because mike
pence was rocking her so
horribly first of all second of all
trump i don't think is threatened by
strong tough women uh his campaign was
run
by the first woman ever to run a
successful presidential campaign
kellyanne conway
kept her in the white house as long as
he possibly could sarah sanders pretty
strong to me kaylee mcinerney pretty
strong to me whole picks pretty strong
to me
he surrounded himself with more top
female advisors than like any president
in history
and then the popular vote he's he's he's
so bothered that hillary won the popular
vote
the popular vote and a buck 50 will get
you a cup of coffee
there the popular vote is completely
meaningless
we have a federal system in this country
we have states in this country
we have a constitution that sets up how
presidential elections work
they don't work on a national vote
because this is not just the united
individuals of america it's the united
states of america
the states play a role and i don't think
that
donald trump sitting in the oval office
has to envy hillary clinton who's
wandering screaming with her broomstick
through the woods of chappaqua
something tells me not very believable
actually the only better and more
ridiculous narrative being spun right
now than that
the only more preposterous narrative
being spun and you're seeing this crop
up
you've been seeing it crop up for a few
months is
just as social media are suppressing
the new york post the oldest continually
published news daily newspaper in the
country founded by alexander hamilton
because they're attacking joe biden just
as conservatives are being kicked off
including the white house press
secretary
just as today i tried to retweet
something but it was negative about
biden
a big pop-up came up and it said read
past the headline the headline doesn't
say everything are you sure you want to
retweet this i say yeah
sure and then when you try to retweet it
you can't retweet you've got it goes to
a comment tweet and they're just doing
everything they can to suppress it
amid all of this facebook doing it as
well google less so
right now because they're afraid of
getting broken up by the doj but they
also do it
the left is trying to argue that social
media are biased
in favor of conservatives i kid you not
i kid you not they're making this
argument that
zuckerberg is in bed with ben shapiro
and dan bongino and whatever all these
conservative people i can promise you
i've never shared a bed with mark
zuckerberg first of all
but they use these completely false
lines of attack they say that
republicans get more engagement
and or conservatives get more engagement
on on facebook for instance which is the
one they they usually hone in on
conservatives get more engagement than
liberals that's not true not true at all
not even close to true they say that uh
conservatives have
have a wider reach than liberals not
true not even closer to jeremy actually
just launched a new podcast about this
called enough he has a great episode
that just came out
i think it's called enough about this
nonsense he goes through the numbers i
highly recommend you subscribe to it
it's on all the podcast platforms
go check it out once you finish
listening to the show because it
completely knocks it down and they're
going to try to use this
argument to completely kick
conservatives off of social media
if heaven forfeit joe biden wins
the presidential election that's that's
the most ridiculous of all forget the
giuliani stuff everything like that
the media are obviously very insecure
about this fact you can tell
that the media and the big tech and the
democratic elected officials are
insecure
because they explode whenever you call
them on it
a susan ferrecchio from the washington
examiner was just speaking with brian
stelter
you know brian stelter of cnn fame and
she brought up how the press are not
asking joe biden
about anything they're not asking about
any of the scandals that have cropped up
brian stelter i thought his head was
going to explode he's running for
president of the united states and this
is serious
this is not last year's news it's
whether or not
his son was coordinating to get him to
talk to these ukraine oligarchs
and he was benefiting from it i mean
it's just it's it's really dirty
forgive me bryce delta then i want to
move on to the google which is a related
story brian
i you know you i said it was last season
you're saying it's new
uh i think bottom line is we don't know
what is real and what is fake in these
emails if there is anything real in them
yeah but that doesn't stop any from from
reporting the mueller and the dossier
and all that stuff
i understand that you have a lot of
resentment about now now we have ethics
oh okay now we have ethics don't you
dare don't you dare act like newsrooms
didn't have ethics
in 2017 and 2018. well i know they thank
you well you can't you can don't dare me
all you want brian i've been doing this
for 30 years so
say whatever you want it's my view and i
have a right to say it i wasn't
my view is that the news media was
unethical with mueller like i said one
of the time i don't quite get what
you're saying
yes the news media were unethical with
mueller and with
every other hoax of the past four years
what they're saying now what brian
salter is saying now is we don't want to
ask joe biden about
the document dump that we just saw that
shows
collusion and corruption and
whatever other nefarious crime they
accused trump of for the past four years
that shows joe biden committing those
crimes in ukraine and china
we don't want to ask him about that
because we don't know if it's true
you're journalists you're reporters
you're supposed to find out if it's true
right now you're using this lame excuse
that it's russian disinformation the
director of national intelligence and
the doj and the fbi
all came out and said that's bs it's not
russian disinformation
so how about you ask about it you didn't
mind asking about the completely
fabricated
christopher steele dossier which was
paid for by the hillary campaign and the
democrats
you didn't mind asking him about that
you asked about that all the time you
don't mind asking about this ridiculous
conspiracy theory that donald trump is a
white supremacist
that nobody ever floated until he ran
for president as a republican he
disavows
disavows all the time you don't mind
about that you don't mind asking about
the
the taxes or the stormy daniels or
whatever all that nonsense
they have no ethics whatsoever and the
reason he's exploding about it is
because he knows it
you know these things they get me really
worked up
and when i get really worked up
sometimes i want to work out and that's
why i use my total gym
total gym new partner to the show i am
so honored
to be a partner with total gym you will
remember total gym
if you have been watching tv for any
time in the past i don't know 20 years
because you have chuck norris and
christy brinkley are the ones who are
always talking
about the total gym and i'm very honored
now to join
that powerful duo i want to i want when
people think
of of chuck norris i want them to think
chuck norris
and and christy brinkley and michael
knowles yeah that's very you know i want
there to be jokes on the internet about
me and chuck like you know beneath my
beard there's another fist or whatever
i'm very excited not just about chuck
norris but about the gym itself because
now i'm gonna look like chuck norris
they've got the total gym fit gives me a
full body workout
in the comfort of my home for about half
the price of those expensive fitness
bikes
you know what i'm talking about you can
do over 85 exercises on one machine
and what makes it so effective is that
it works every muscle group using 12
levels of resistance you can work your
core your arms your shoulders your
biceps your thighs
your whole body and a complete workout
takes just 10 to 20 minutes a day which
means
it's simple enough even i can do it even
i'm willing to do it
and now they have total gym tv by the
way with total tons of on-demand
workouts
we're all busier than ever these days
why would you go out to a gym
when you can work out in the comfort of
your own home head on over right now
total gym's offering a 30 day in-home
trial
on the total gym fit for just one dollar
one dollar so what do you have to lose
no matter which total gym you try
my listeners can get an additional 20
off whatever discount they're currently
running
so it's not just 20 off total it's
whatever discount they're currently
running take another 20
off total gym direct.com knowles head on
over there to get this offer
total gymdirect.com get an additional 20
off or you can just call them and talk
to an actual
human being at 1-800-311-7166
1-800-311-7166
i do have to get to a little bit of good
news right now
about the election which is which is a
good poll
for president trump but before i get
that i want to cross the pond head on
over
to the united kingdom because there is a
british
member of parliament who is
focusing in on one of the key sources of
rot
in our civilization and in our culture
and it's affecting not just the u.s
not just the uk it's affecting the whole
western world and that this is something
called
critical race theory comes from critical
theory you've heard us
mention this on the show a little bit
sometimes critical theory is
actually pretty simple theory the theory
is to criticize this was developed
by neo-marxists in the 1920s 30s and 40s
really though it developed out of the
frankfurt school especially in the 1930s
and 40s
and the idea is to engage in what marx
called the ruthless criticism of
everything that exists
this is where we get political
correctness from in large part
the idea that we're going to completely
subvert the old standards of our
civilization
so there's this great mp uh dawn butler
in the uk or i'm sorry
the mp dawn butler is a labor
mp but the women and equalities minister
kemi
badanok is uh is
calling out this critical race theory
take
a listen to this absolute evisceration
our curriculum does not need
decolonizing for the simple reason that
it is not colonized
we should not apologize for the fact
that british children primarily study
the history of these islands and it goes
without saying that the recent fad
to decolonize maths decolonize
engineering decolonize the sciences that
we have seen across our universities
to make race the defining principle of
what is studied
is not just misguided but actively
opposed to the fundamental purpose of
education
the curriculum by its very nature is
limited there are a finite number of
hours to teach any subject
and what we haven't heard in this debate
from those members who want
more added to it on both sides of the
house is what necessarily must be taken
out
perhaps we'll get to that on another day
i love this point
and it's one that i don't hear
conservatives making and we should all
listen to this lady
which is what the left says when they
want to get rid of shakespeare at yale
at in
as a course requirement in the english
department or they want to get rid of
chaucer
or whatever or they want to teach some
bs revisionist history instead of the
real history
what they say is we want to expand the
curriculum
we want to decolonize the curriculum
which
the idea that you're going to decolonize
the english department
by taking shakespeare out i think maybe
you don't understand the meaning of the
word colonize
i don't colonize is when you
have a power go into a foreign land and
control it
shakespeare is not foreign to english
shakespeare in many ways
invented the english language he's
certainly contributed greatly to our
modern
english the idea that because you've got
old white guys in an english curriculum
that's colonization
it's very silly when you remember that
the english people
are white and writers for most of
history have been men
and good writers are dead generally
speaking because there have been
a lot more there's been a lot more time
in the
history of the english language than
what we're living in right now
she hits on all of that but then she
goes to this point she says
we can't just kind of outsource this
idea and say well we'll expand it we'll
just have choice and
maybe some people want to read
shakespeare maybe some people want to
read i don't know slam poetry and
you know we'll just have choice and
choice and choice you can't do that
there are only so many hours in the day
you yourself the educator have to make
choices
every extra minute you spend reading
slam poetry you're
not going to be reading shakespeare
every minute you spend reading the 16 19
project
you're not going to be reading true
history
you have to make those choices education
is limited education is coercive
you've got to teach people things
sometimes you're the slogan
that it's not that we want to teach
people what to think we we just want to
teach them how to think but that is a
completely meaningless slogan
you cannot teach people how to think
without teaching them what to think
if i want to teach people how to think
about mathematics i have to teach them
that two plus two equals four that's a
fact that i'm teaching them
if i want to teach someone how to think
about ethics and philosophy i have to
teach them that
it is wrong to commit murder or that it
is wrong to steal
and you know the left has no problem
with this the left will teach you that
it is not wrong to commit murder through
abortion or that it is not wrong to
steal through
confiscatory policies or outright
looting that's what they're going to
tell you
and then that's going to teach you how
to think and
if you have that kind of an education
it's going to it's not going to teach
you
how to think very well it does matter
what we teach we have
to get past this idea that we're afraid
to make
substantive moral statements that we're
afraid to say
to suppress stupid views we do we have
to
if you're going to teach the 2 plus 2
equals 4 you have to suppress the stupid
view
the two plus two equals five if you're
going to teach that america was founded
in 1776 or 1620 for that matter
you you have to suppress you have to
shut down you have to reject the stupid
view that america was founded
in 1619 that is how you teach people
that lady in the uk gets it we should
get it over here
as well one last good piece of news a
very top pollster the trafalgar group
chief polster rudy
kahaly got 2016 mostly right showed
donald trump leading hillary clinton in
key battleground states
and trump won all three of those
pennsylvania florida and michigan
he is calling trump to win again
in 2020. i know we're all worried about
the polls and the polls in the polls but
this guy
does have a really good record i'm not
saying this is a guarantee that trump's
gonna win
but it is definitely a good sign in his
favor
it's a good uh i would say when you're
when you're planning out your future
you know when you're trying to figure
out how to invest in your own future
then you want to take in good
information this guy
is more reliable than a lot of the other
people out there another way to invest
in your future
is gold you know gold has been
skyrocketing lately and now there's a
way to buy gold
through a company called acre acre lets
you subscribe to gold bars for as little
as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house acre lets you invest in physical
gold without coming out of pocket
all at once acre keeps you updated on
your gold stash every month and it ships
once you reach that price threshold
because i think listen i'd like to
invest in gold but
we don't all have the equivalent of gold
bars lying around in cash
it's fine you can start investing now
and once you hit that price threshold
you will get your gold bars go to
getacre.com knowles and start investing
in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away
a gold bar they're just giving one away
to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at
get underscore acre that is g-e-t
underscore a-c-r-e
that is get getacregold.com knowles
thank you akergold for supporting this
show we really appreciate it
also we're gonna have a backstage
tonight you know we've got the final
presidential debate
they're gonna try to mute trump's
microphone trump's not gonna have it
fireworks will fly
join us for the daily wire backstage at
8 45 pm eastern 5 45 pm
pacific for this all new episode join
daily wire now as an insider or all
access member
get 20 20 off with code debate
so you can watch all the debate coverage
live on our apple tv or roku app
we will be right back with mailbag
first question from isaac dear michael
according to the catholic voter guide
biden sides more with catholic values
i wanted to get your thoughts on this
best regards yeah the catholic voter
guide
is complete nonsense i i took a look at
this
as well this is i think it may be put
out with the approval of the u.s council
of catholic bishops i once spoke to a
priest who told me
he was considering writing his own blank
book on the order of my blank book
with my blank book as reasons to vote
for democrats he was suggesting the
wisdom of the u.s council of catholic
bishops
a lot of mistakes get made i took a
quick look at the voter guide
some parts of it are just outright lies
they're saying that biden
aligns more with catholic values because
he promotes peace and opposes preemptive
war
and with trump that's either
inconclusive or it does not align
with catholic values joe biden voted for
the war in iraq
for the pre-emptive war in iraq donald
trump opposed the war in iraq
the catholic voter guide got that
exactly backwards
another another problem with the
catholic voter guide they're saying that
a federal
jobs guarantee a 100 jobs guarantee is a
catholic value that is not true
that is socialism or communism which is
explicitly forbidden
in the catholic church in the catechism
and by many many popes and saints
i'm reading a great book now witness by
whitaker chambers
one of the great books of american
political literature
and chambers who's an ex-communist
describes communism as
the the world's second old oldest
religion the first one is true religion
and the world's second oldest religion
is communism because communism is
basically just the choice
between believing in god or believing in
man
believing in grace and in god
or believing in the mind of man trying
to be as gods goes back all the way to
the garden of eden
so yeah not a catholic value another
another
issue it had is they talked about how we
need equal pay
and we need high women's employment and
biden alliance with
those catholic values and and trump does
not
first of all women's employment is not a
catholic value
i think catholic church is perfectly
fine if women want to stay home and
raise their kids i don't think they're
saying you've got to go to the widget
factory and become a middle manager
also equal pay already exists the idea
that women make 25 75 cents on the
dollar is just not true
but but even if let's say female
unemployment
were a catholic value you know women all
have to go into the workforce
trump still aligns best with catholic
values because you have the lowest
women's unemployment rate
practically ever another one is they
said
joe biden is better on social security
which is a catholic
value trump is pro-social security
that's not inconclusive
that is conclusive for trump he said i'm
not going to touch your social security
open borders is not a catholic value
though the voter guide suggests that it
is
goes on and on and on so one way to
think about this is first of all
even if the the voter guide had no
issues for the rest of it
it is simply the case that some issues
are more important than others
such as abortion abortion is much more
important than some issue about taxation
or something like that
so even even if biden aligned on so many
other issues but he were
in favor of abortion and taxpayer-funded
abortion
that's a deal-breaker the catholic voter
guide
is wrong on issues of politics
on those political points also wrong
about the catholic church
and i would recommend ignoring it from
julia dear mr knowles my name is julia i
am a 16 year old black and dutch
conservative
my family and i live in the netherlands
but love to follow american politics my
mom came
came up with the idea to move to the u.s
for a year with me her
my little sister and my best friend i
think this might be an interesting
adventure but i'm not sure
what are your thoughts on this and where
do you think we should live if we move
you're sincerely p.s i'm a big fan and
you and your show got me into reading
the bible with my family that's so great
i'm very glad to hear that julia and i
would love for you to come to america
because it sounds like you've got a
great head on your shoulders and you can
maybe help us out over here
but i will tell you things are a little
turbulent right now
in the united states i would recommend
coming after the election i suspect
you're probably not going to come
before the election uh if you do come
if you would ask me this five years ago
i'd say go to new york center of the
universe the most fun place in the world
or even l.a come out to la right these
are they're left-wing cities but you
know they're very nice they're fun
they're exciting you can
there's a lot of opportunity there
there's a lot of conservatives there too
because of kovid they're not so fun new
york has basically been completely
broken
i think something like 60 of restaurants
they're expected to go out of business
people are fleeing the city
same thing in la things are not going
very well in l.a one thing you're seeing
in
in america right now is the country is
balkanizing conservatives are going to
red states
leftists are going to blue states daily
wires moving to tennessee for this
reason
you sort of have to do it they've backed
us into a corner here
so you might consider moving to a
red state but you might want a city
there too i would recommend
nashville nashville is a pretty great
place you might have fun if you haven't
visited new york yet
it is a great city i think right now
though it's just been completely
destroyed
washington dc is great i love dc it's
another place to go
but my recommendation i don't know just
popped into my head it's nashville great
place
from paul michael is matt walsh a clone
of jeremy boring
or vice versa
it's a great question scientists have
debated this for a long time
i think what they did is that one night
the
opus dei and the knights of malta
and various secret catholic groups
kidnapped jeremy boring
cloned him and then just injected him
with a with a huge amount of catholicism
which is jeremy himself not very
catholic and then
out of that laboratory popped mount
walsh so that's i think that's the the
chronological order from mitch could
president trump when he walks into
thursday night's debate possibly strut
out and slap a bumper sticker on the
front of his podium that simply reads
i denounce all forms of racism white
supremacy and neo-nazis
i know the vast majority of americans
are undoubtedly unclear as it is
positioned on the matter
just thought this could be a solution to
clear it up once
and for all and allow the moderator to
focus on more pressing matters of
substance
all hail the exalted dr fauci peace be
upon him yeah it's a very good idea
because very likely it's the only way
that trump is going to get a word in
edgewise at tonight's debate
they're going to control the microphones
and they're saying they're not going to
let the microphones be turned on
while the other person is speaking which
really means they're just going to use
this to cut off trump although i was
talking to drew clavin about this
yesterday
he thinks it might be used to cut off
biden when he starts rambling
incoherently if trump gives them the
chance to speak
so yes i agree the way to get around the
media is to
smack a bumper sticker on it or to do
what president trump has done
kind of create such a big show that the
media are not allowed
to look away and then while you're doing
that show you get your message out it's
why people who
criticize trump for the tweets or for
some of the eccentric behavior they
don't get it
the eccentric behavior in the tweets or
the way that he gets the camera on him
so that he can get his message through
it it's
inefficient i grant you but notice that
trump is the only
president who's been able to break
through to the american people probably
since ronald reagan
maybe even more so from joshua one more
based on the polls in 2016
i do not trust them currently i think if
the president is within four to five
points in battleground states in the
polls
he wins those states your thoughts i
agree i
was talking to dave rubin about this
actually yesterday
and adam corolla actually for that we
were kind of all chatting about what
what do the polls mean
and one of these guys was saying nobody
is a biden voter
who is not going to tell the pollsters
that he's a biden voter right nobody is
the embarrassed biden voter
who's afraid of voicing his political
opinion so whatever percentage of people
are saying they're going to vote for
biden
they're really going to vote for bud
now there are there are trump voters who
are pretending to be biden voters
because they're afraid
or they're trump voters who are saying
they don't they're undecided or they're
not going to vote or something
because they're afraid so it seems to me
biden is probably capped
where he is in the polls whereas trump i
think there are some hidden voters in
there
who because of our political climate
they don't want to get a brick thrown in
through their window
so they're they're going to play it a
little bit cooler
i think that's a good way to read the
polls we'll see different polls are
different i mentioned the trafalgar
it's got a pretty good record but
generally speaking
i look at the polls as instruments of
shaping public opinion rather than
reflecting them
and the only poll that matters is the
one on election day all right that's our
show
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you next week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen